[Música]
é preciso olhar pra dentro
para fazer nascer fora o mundo onde a
gente quer viver
eu levei 50 anos para acreditar que era
verdade
trinta de 50 anos trabalhando pra
políticos e corporações estudando
comportamentos e desenvolvendo
estratégias que convenciam a maior parte
das pessoas de que tudo que elas
precisavam estava fora
eu ajudei a construir um mundo que não
revelou mais do que mais de nós do que a
nossa capacidade de conquistar de
dominar de construir de competir de
fazer o que a gente quisesse fazer
simplesmente porque a gente queria fazer
num desses momentos que eu parei pra me
perguntar por que eu usava o que eu
sabia fazer pra fazer o que eu fazia eu
fui para a singularity na califórnia no
vale do silício um lugar que discutia a
velocidade ea necessidade da revolução
tecnológica ganhar velocidade na
capacidade que essa revolução tem de
transformar nossa realidade
eu compartilho muito com uma idéia
colocada pela singular e de que a gente
precisa criar uma nova fm fm baseada na
abundância porque do ponto de vista
social o que nós fazemos todos os dias é
trabalhar com medo da falta
nós conquistamos nós lutamos todos os
dias pra ter coisas porque a gente tem
medo que falte a gente tem medo que
acabe a gente vive
movidos pelo medo da escassez ea gente
acumula para que não falte
mesmo ignorando aquilo que a gente deixa
de não positivo pelo caminho
quando voltei da singular de alguma
coisa me incomodava muito e eu demorei a
descobrir o que e eu acabei me
conectando com algo que era tão grande
de repente eu tinha descoberto o lugar
onde a gente estava no mundo
a gente está podendo muito
é muito engraçado isso é como se a gente
tivesse se tornando deus nós estamos
podendo cada vez mais criar a nossa
capacidade de realização está na nossa
melhor forma mas a gente está discutindo
pouco resíduos velocidade impacto
limites e conseqüências de verdade não
importa se a gente está sentado aqui
nessa sala agora no vale do silício
o que a gente faz todos os dias é
recriar o mundo
nós criamos novos contextos com textos
individuais novos contextos sociais
novos contextos culturais novos
contextos coletivos com textos que
transformam a forma como nós olhamos
para nós mesmos
a forma como nós exploramos o mundo e
outro a forma como nós ganhamos
perspectivas é muito interessante porque
de verdade enquanto nós fazemos isso o
que de verdade nós fazemos ao investir
no desenvolvimento tecnológico é
influenciar a nossa percepção da
realidade e os nossos valores
nós estamos vendo mais e mais camadas
mais perspectivas sobreposições de
realidades interligadas a sistemas
relacionais complexos como indivíduos
sociedade corporações mídia governos
organizações e meio ambiente
nós estamos despertando para novas
realidades e para a realidade que muitas
vezes nós vamos achar que são novas mas
que sempre estiveram em um despertar que
ao mesmo tempo revela novas
possibilidades novos sentidos e
significados
e coloca em risco valores sociais
vigentes fazendo surgir um tipo de
fricção que muita gente vai tentar
resolver
dando força para antigas convicções e
fazendo crescer o conservadorismo
a sobreposição de tantas realidades gera
flexões tensões e resíduos que ainda
tentamos resolver isolando fatores e
reduzindo riscos
nós seguimos criando tensões resíduos
que nem sempre se resolvem que nem
sempre precisam ser resolvidos mas que
muita gente muitas vezes geram fricções
que se transforma em confrontos
enquanto isso acontece nós continuamos
criando revoluções que nos permitem
poder mais uma dessas revoluções está
fazendo muita diferença agora é a
revolução maker que parece que é nascido
para nos tirar da posição despertadores
do nosso próprio destino
uma posição que nós nos colocamos todas
as vezes que nós decidimos não escolher
aquilo que nos define como pessoa
aquilo que diz quem somos onde vivemos
o lugar para onde nós estamos indo não
há como negar que a revolução nem quer
ela tem o potencial de romper com regras
e princípios que foram definidos por uma
revolução industrial
aparentemente não escravagistas uma
revolução industrial que nos convidou a
não ter tempo nem paciência para
absolutamente nada que fosse feito por
nós mesmos revolução maker como no ato
político tá gritando pela nossa
independência e enquanto ela grita pela
nossa independência
nós precisamos ganhar mais consciente
do caminho que nós vamos percorrer para
chegar no lugar onde a gente acredita
que a gente precisa chegar nós não
podemos esquecer nós criamos o mundo que
hoje nós queremos mudar e as últimas
décadas foram absolutamente fascinante
em nos mostrar o que nós deixamos pelo
caminho enquanto nós nos tornávamos as
pessoas que nós somos hoje é muito
importante perguntar o que nós queremos
deixar pelo caminho enquanto nós vamos
nos tornar as pessoas que nós queremos
ser
por isso convido vocês a pensar que tipo
de resíduo
nós estamos produzindo agora nós estamos
produzindo desconfiança e medo
há 18 anos a é de uma empresa
internacional de comunicação realiza um
estudo onde ela conversa com pessoas em
36 países com o objetivo de entender
como se formam as relações que
estabelecemos com as corporações com a
mídia com as organizações não
governamentais e com os governos nos
últimos dez anos
esse estudo tem mostrado a fragilização
dessas relações e apontado para um risco
muito importante nesse momento nós nossa
relação de confiança
não é mais como ela já foi estabelecida
antes
nesse momento nós estamos olhando para
fora e nos perguntando quem está por mim
62% das pessoas acreditam que o sistema
entrou em colapso
nós estamos vendo mais realidades e
produzindo mais flexões reflexões que
poderiam ser muito positiva
nós andamos porque os nossos pés e
flexionam com o solo as flexões numa nos
mantém movimento
nós precisamos dela para criar um mundo
novo
mas nesse momento nós não estamos nos
sentindo fortes e poderosos o suficiente
para impedir que as fricções se
transforme em confronto
a desconfiança é uma realidade na
maioria dos países estudados pela é
dilma
nós estamos perdendo o jogo no campo das
relações humanas
nosso sistema de crenças está em risco
por um motivo simples
nós estamos confiando cada vez menos uns
nos outros
junto com a desconfiança surgiu o medo o
medo que pode nos fazer lutar contra
aquilo que tem o poder de nos
transformar positivamente nesse momento
nós temos medo da corrupção da
globalização do desgaste dos valores
sociais da imigração do ritmo da
inovação no brasil essa situação é ainda
pior quando nós olhamos para fora
não encontramos nada que alimenta a
nossa esperança sem razão para acreditar
nos tornamos menos generosos menos
abertos a ouvir - abertos a dialogar
menos capazes de criar espaços comuns de
acolhimento
nós estamos quatro vezes mais propensos
a ignorar qualquer informação contrária
aquilo que a gente acredita
originalmente no brasil e se ainda pior
sem confiança
a dissonância que nasce do encontro do
nosso desejo de transformar o mundo com
a nossa natural busca de segurança pode
fazer surgir um tipo de confronto capaz
de aumentar o medo e fazer crescer o
conservadorismo um conservadorismo que
abre espaço para o populismo o fascismo
mesmo nós precisamos olhar para fora com
a consciência de que estamos olhando
para nós mesmos
a revolução que precisa acontecer agora
é humana uma revolução dependente de uma
resolução individual que ninguém pode
produzir artificialmente as respostas
que estamos procurando estão dentro de
nós temos todos os mecanismos
necessários para encontrá las como no
nosso mundo exterior
o nosso mundo interior é repleto de
camadas de diferentes dimensões por
dentro nós também somos consequências da
sobreposição de realidades interligadas
a sistemas relacionais complexos como
coração
o corpo a espiritualidade a
ancestralidade nesse momento com todo
nosso poder de criação na sua melhor
forma depois de ter revelado fora toda a
nossa complexidade
nosso grande desafio um convite para
descobrir quem nós realmente somos
a consciência de quem nós realmente
somos é a única capaz de gerar o
antídoto necessário para fazer com que a
gente vença no campo das relações
humanas e recupera a esperança
o sonho a confiança que são necessários
pra que a gente de verdade realiza é
aquilo que precisa ser feito a revolução
que importa tá dentro de cada um de nós
e nós podemos decidir agora se nós
queremos ou não fazer com que essa
revolução aconteça você quer começar a
mudar o mundo agora
[Aplausos]